when i saw that someone stole a billion
dollars in nfts by right-clicking all of
them i instantly wanted to steal them
too after all it's just kind of funny
the idea of having every nft in
existence contained in one single hard
drive lucky for me the person who
created it hosted the project on
something called nft bay and he offered
a torrent for anyone who wanted it yes i
know lock me up uh i was here to steal
all your nfts that was the plan except
well
there's a pretty big file now looking at
my current disk size i decided that
would be kind of impractical and even if
i wanted to download this it would take
me like six months with my current
internet speed so my next idea was just
to contact the creator jeffrey and see
if he'd be willing to help me find some
way to get the files faster i told him
to think of the kits his response was
this he said it's dangerous to actually
get them ipfs is essentially dark web
downloading images from dark web and
distributing them on mass would be a
lovely way to get to jail fast
especially if you're talking about
blindly just downloading them all now i
was confused he had downloaded them why
couldn't i he replied i took steps to
protect myself and anyone who jumped on
the torrent it's funny actually maybe we
can catch up tomorrow i decided that
would be a good idea maybe he could
explain how he could get this billion
dollar nft heist but when i got on the
call our conversation took a totally
different turn and i want you to hear it
wait a second the nft bay holds all the
nfts but doesn't
no it doesn't
when i created the project originally i
said it was an art project
and i along the way i realized to
demonstrate the message that needed to
be conveyed to teach people
about nfts the actual data did not
matter what is the message i mean you
have a 17 terabyte file well
the message is
what are people actually
purchasing with nfts
coffee
like what do you what do people think
that they're actually purchasing i
imagine they think they're buying a
picture basically right the rights to a
picture most of the time most of the
time that's most what most people think
of in a teaser yeah the one way i like
to look at it is you've got one side
that's essentially selling a treasure
map or directions
on how to get to treasure and the other
side thinks that they're buying treasure
the actual treasure on one side
we've got people that think that they're
buying the artwork the treasure
right and that's what they think is
value and the other side we have people
exploiting those people so and selling
treasure maps how to get to the treasure
so what i wanted to highlight in in the
project is a lot of people were saying
that the
image is valuable the artwork is
valuable because it's stored on the
blockchain it's not stored in the
blockchain it's just a hyperlink wait
wait hold on a second when i buy an nft
of a board ape or a lazy lion
i'm not actually purchasing
that picture
what am i actually buying no
you're essentially buying a
a piece of data and that data is has a
link to where the image can be located
so like a url
is that what you're saying it's a url go
look at e for scan and look at the
contract and have a look at it literally
people are buying a link
like directions on a treasure map to a
treasure and they're saying that the
treasure of the artwork and the only
reason people are buying stuff is for
the treasure or the artwork but what's
actually been sold is the directions to
the treasure
wait a second i know a lot of people
like why not just host the file on the
blockchain why not just host the picture
on the blockchain
because the cost the cost
in 2016 it was calculated it would cost
76 000
per gigabyte to store on the blockchain
oh it's gotta have gotten worse way
worse there's been block chain size
increases and the costs have got worse
it'd be nice to do that calculation
again
but yeah so back to your original
question what's in the torrent well it
contains
chunks of blockchain data the nfts
themselves and it the rest is if you're
from a unix background f allocate now
when i launched the project i said
specifically that this would be uploaded
to internet archive and it's now on the
internet archive and it serves as just
an example of of the art project of
spreading the message of what people are
actually purchasing and it compressed
from
18 terabytes down to 12 gigabytes
you're gonna really people off with this
one i got to tell you geoffrey um
finding this out i do find it ironic
that number one i was so excited about
this i just took it at face value but
also i noticed a lot of media companies
did too i mean you got the bbc the verge
vice
and many more to run articles about this
nft heist i guess you heisted the nfts
but everyone's thinking of you like
right-clicking nfts
but you didn't do that no
it's actually quite dangerous to heist
or the nfts because if you think about
it
what's actually happening is that nft by
definition is essentially an artwork is
a linking to a file yeah
right and if you were to download all
the links to file and then you were to
share that with the world that's
actually quite legally dangerous oh
right well because it could have
anything on there anyways it's the
internet it can have anything ipfs is
essentially the dark web right and
anyone
can put anything onto the blockchain
anyone can put anything onto the
blockchain and so if you're talking
about downloading all the links from all
the blockchain and then serving that
that's probably a bad idea was that an
intended effect of this whole project is
that like most people
would not only confuse you but also just
take you
at face value sort of like what people
are doing with nfts where i'm buying a
board ape i see a picture of a board ape
so i assume that's what i'm buying but
in actual fact you're telling me i'm
actually buying a like a hyperlink or
like a pointer to that file which i
technically do not own i mean i or do i
it's confusing you don't own it yeah it
is confusing there actually are some
nfts and to be clear there's some nfts
where the quality of the nft is so poor
it's like pixel art that they don't need
to link it to elsewhere they don't need
a link as a hyperlink but that is like
the exception most are actually
hyperlinks to an image kotaku described
it as the heist of the century right
because like all the nfts have been
downloaded it's
always was a
performance artwork just to write that
their unpopular culture
of
everyone one side is saying these have
value and the other side is saying they
don't have value and it was just this
beautiful pop culture piece to like
focus the narrative on educating people
what they're actually buying so in some
ways yes it was a heist but it wasn't
the highest of the actual images well it
was actually somewhat of a media heist
yeah and also kind of the highest of
what the nft's actually are right
because you
you did actually download the blockchain
in the the
the nft bay
so in a way you actually have the
what actually those people own which is
the hyperlinks but you don't have the
files which they also don't have which
is kind of
yeah that
i get
i get what you're doing you're going to
mix a lot of people off with this one
but i i do have to ask okay do you own
the ifps like address like let's say i
buy i buy a uh pudgy penguin do i own
that domain where the file is located
what do i own you own a entry in a
database that directs you how to access
that image on ipfs that's it so
theoretically someone could go in and
change the data at the ifps or the drive
link or wherever they're storing the
data it happens all the time if you're
following nfts and the developments it's
called a rug pull they sell the database
entry on blockchain and blockchain is
immutable and it cannot be updated but
they host the image elsewhere say on
google photos or google drive and then
once the art is art is sold the database
entry is sold they just switch it to a
picture of a rug
okay so yeah
so it's a play on the rug pool that's
good that's really uh is that common
it's super common so this was this isn't
a rug pool this is something else this
is originally and always was meant to be
something that's a little bit funny it's
a pop cultural reference and also spark
conversation about intellectual property
ownership
and
is the nft valuable it is funny that all
these people who
see themselves as like seeing through
what an nft is
covered your piece
but didn't understand actually what it
was um
myself sort of included here's my
thought if this is all true like doesn't
this mean that people who the joke of
like right click save as you know of
somebody else's nfc picture whatever
it's kind of like they own it more than
you do as the nft owner you own the
blockchain like database link like you
own a link
they own you don't even own the link you
just have a link
they own the actual data
who owns the pudgy penguin more the guy
with the actual data or the guy with
like the pointer to the data
that's exactly that's what's so funny
that's why i use the expression treasure
maps and treasure right so if you have
the treasure the pudgy penguin you have
the treasure meanwhile everyone is
selling links or
links to the treasure now this is the
funny thing let's say the pudgy penguin
exists on a web host somewhere
there's nothing stopping people from
creating multiple
links or multiple nfts or multiple
treasure maps to that treasure and it
happens all the time there is no proof
of authenticity you can create it's you
can have one treasure and a thousand
treasure maps i guess they would argue
oh it's just about who's creating the
treasure map if it's like yeah this is
what's confusing to me look i'm gonna
play devil's advocate for a second here
i think a lot of people would say okay
this is very cute but everyone just sort
of accepts nfts
have value and there has to be a place
for digital artists this is where i'm at
i think it's good that we can digital
artists can make a living i just think
it's been hijacked by a bunch of scams
what do you think this means
for
what nfts are or could be sold as
it's a tough question i suppose we have
to look at where we are right now in
society if we look at things very
carefully we have over a billion dollars
in venture capital invested by venture
capitalists like
a solid billion of venture capital has
been poured into the technology industry
to find a use for blockchain our
technologists have yet to find a proper
use for blockchain we're still trying to
find the use
at the same time we have social media
influencers that are available for
purchase and then finally we have the
final final thing which is the
communities
we have uh
dowse which essentially
you you buy a token the token the best
way i can explain that is timeshare so
to join the community you buy a piece of
timeshare and now your ownership of that
timeshare you're now
incentivized to
promote it so we've got companies who
invested money in company we've got
venture capitalists convention a lot of
money into companies incentivized to
promote we've got social media
influencers who are getting paid to
promote and get a cut and now all of a
sudden we've got communities themselves
that are now incentivized to promote so
it's really hard to tell what is natural
if we we look back historically at how
communities formed people turn up around
an art project because they love it they
think it's cool it's got a vibe it's got
what else have you but now with
tokenization of everything people are
turning around and turning up because
they can make coin they're financially
vested in this thing doing well i do
think it's weird too look sometimes when
i call out scams the community freaks
out i mean
because they are financially
uh
sort of vested they're activist
investors basically is what they what
you can
create if you uh
sort of have these communities
like spring up
do you think nfts are worthless
i don't know
i do know that a lot of people are being
exploited aiming left to help hold the
bag it's funny you mention any criticism
because any criticism automatically gets
said that's that's fun right
right they just they just dismiss it all
as fud yeah it doesn't matter how
rational of a of an argument you can put
forward that even the technology
industry is seriously divided about
these technologies and we've yet to find
a util a usage for it but meanwhile
we've got art galleries with 1.4 million
twitter followers about to do an nfc
gallery sale and we've got people i'm
getting emails as a result in a t bay of
people like i don't have a job i'm
trying to put my son through college
i've just got some coin i saw i i got
the uh the crypto the crypto.com wallet
i've got the coinbase wallet which coins
should i purchase can you give me some
free nfts i want to i want to change my
life i think a lot of people are going
to take issue with the idea there's been
no use found for it i think a lot of
people are gonna say okay yeah it's a
new technology they're gonna liken it to
the internet look the internet you
couldn't have expected much early on you
would have missed what it's gonna become
and how it's gonna change everything
they would say look same thing with
crypto give us 10 years we'll build that
future you kind of got to just like
trust us it's factually correct that
we've yet to find actual use for this
technology yet
does it mean that in the future we make
like money i mean like for guys like as
like a currency i mean as like these
these smart chain things
they uh they're really interesting i
think there's some cool uses of it i i
think you could make the argument oh you
can do everything that you can do on a
smart chain in like a website or
whatever but i guess the idea is that
it's you can decentralize it you don't
have to have anything running it you can
replace a lot of fin stuff with like new
fintechs i don't know i think you could
find something yeah but that's i i'm
open i i went through the early internet
and i see a lot of things that people
are building it reminds me of the early
internet so i'm hoping that there could
be value in the future but the thing
that that worries me right now and
especially in the nft space i'm getting
emails from people who are essentially
saying i'm buying coins because i hope
to change my life right so we still
haven't found utility and meanwhile the
the these coins are increasing in value
there's these if you go to twitter
spaces coffee and just any of the
twitter spill twitter spaces you'll hear
the scams are so brazen oh i i
absolutely agree i mean i share your
your deep concern that a lot of these
coins are going to just wreck people i
suppose what i'm getting at is
is now the right time for those type for
those people who are desperate and who
could be exploited to be getting into
crypto
no but you can't stop them from
you can't stop them from trying and
people are
all very excited about the technology
yeah it's very interesting i think a lot
of people who missed the tech boom
are trying to get in on the blockchain
and get themselves rich
without understanding what's sort of
going on and this is why i find this
project actually so interesting
is because you're sort of
uncovering that like a lot of us do not
understand
nfts too well like when you here's
another question when when i buy an nft
do i own the copyright to that nft some
nfts yes there they there are things
like board api club they specifically
have gone out there and said that you do
and this is why you're starting to see
things like bought at your club on shoes
etc right they they are the
they are the exception
the majority of the things that you're
seeing now that are created that is not
the case do you think some people say
not even the picture right right right
you're all right yeah you you own the
hyperlink to the picture it's so
confusing
do you agree with people like garyvee
who think that in the future all
contracts are gonna sort of be signed on
the blockchain or done on the blockchain
or you know stuff like this like nfts
basically are going to be tokenized
versions of ownership that could
represent anything a house
uh insurance contract
anything i've been thinking a lot about
that actually i've been actually
thinking of v2 of the nft bay we've got
something cooking but that's not for now
but specifically been thinking about
gary vee and what he's saying there if
you look at how people use their devices
right now like the younger generations
they create alternative accounts they
create sock puppet accounts they're not
they're not under their real names yeah
right so the way they're using
technology and their privacy model is
very different so if we go to that go to
that
idea that everything's conducted on the
blockchain if we're talking about what
the blockchain is it means anyone can
read anyone can read how much money you
have where you shop where you where you
visit
which place which which airline you use
like if everything is on the blockchain
as they talk about that essentially
means anyone can read anything about
your lives and if we look at where we
are right now in society we're seeing a
lot of pushback over facebook and how
facebook is run and how they're using
that information in bad ways and if we
if we hit this blockchain nirvana where
everything's on the blockchain that
we've created a world that is much worse
than just facebook instead of a singular
company owning our data no one
essentially owns your data anyone can
read your data and that's anyone
right because i guess right now we just
have a bunch of wallet addresses and so
it seems like everyone's anonymous we
could fast forward this five years most
of these wallet addresses are gonna have
names attached to them you're gonna see
the macy's you know if if the utopia
comes true i guess you're gonna see the
target blockchain you're gonna see so
when you see your buddy's wallet you're
gonna see everywhere they shop well
right now there's there's actually two
real huge identifiers you can buy an e s
domain or dot eth and that will actually
assign a name to it to a wallet and that
will actually de-anonymize the wallet
i've seen videos of yourself copy where
you've looked at uh nft scams where
they've actually like like that's the
name it's no longer a wallet address
it's a name you can talk over the radio
with right
and the other thing is you can always
see what currently you can see how much
money is in a wallet or how much money
someone owns or has
and how much money was transacted but
with nfts it's not necessarily just
about money it can be a contract and
right now the contract is a link to an
image what happens in the world that we
talk about the the benefits of
immutability and data on the blockchain
is immutable and that is a great thing
but is it really like if anyone can
publish anything as a link and send it
to your to your
wallet
is that a great thing for society yeah i
mean you could send all sorts of crazy
stuff anything
and we we learned a lot of lessons in
web one web two about spam did we not
sure yeah well you already see that in
wallets
where uh like open like an open sea
they've had to make it possible to hide
certain parts because people were
getting all these basically fake
collections spammed into their wallets
famous people's wallets so that other
people would see that and see perceived
value to that collection that's exactly
it so what we've managed to create right
now in the nft space
is a world where you've got to spend
money to
get rid of images that someone has sent
you in the spam now individual like open
c they have the ability to hide said
images and wallets
but that that data is always there on
the blockchain
what happens if that that what is said
to you
is not
what is what was sent to you was not
just like some art to try and pump their
own collection what happens if it was
something worse like a legal material
basically well i'll give you an example
we we had things like the fappening
right or the celebrities they their
nudes got hacked sure what happens when
some person publishes the fappening and
essentially right now you can publish
that information onto their social media
profile and it's like them nude
and it's immutable it's always on the
blockchain and you can never get rid of
it quit talking to us about the
negatives jeffrey i want to hear about
how to pump my bags
i'm just yeah so that's an example that
is that is an example so we built these
systems
where essentially you have to pay money
yeah to burn the nft
or the nft which could be abuse material
yeah but even if you burn it it's always
going to be attached to your name right
the record the record of it will always
be there yeah somebody i guess somebody
theoretically could send you a token
with your address in the metadata like
your personal address
yes you could craft a token to docs oh
my god
against your name that's terrible and
then everyone can see it it is
everyone can see it
we will see tokens for doxing
so we built this open world of utopian
nirvana and people are so focused on
making money now i'm kind of kind of
getting into some of some ideas i have
for future things to demonstrate points
but hopefully through this where i
also
sit down with
educated people as well that yeah in the
future it's very possible we'll have
tokens for doxing people and it's
permanently attached to your wallet
address and so the idea is okay i'll
just burn my wallet i'll get a new
wallet it's easy to get a new wallet
right and then some person you see the
stuff that happens on youtube and the
drama like some person just like oh
they've got a new wall all right let's
dox them again and there's no
mitigations there's no spam filters
there's no nothing anyone can write
anything on the blockchain and send it
to your wallet it's a inbox a spam inbox
that anyone can write to with no
mitigations right now i guess that
except that it costs them money if you
can get your casino advertised on kanye
west's social media profile is it worth
100
definitely so cost isn't even even a
barrier
so you're highlighting all these
problems of a technology
do you think that the innovations will
scale i mean i i think with all things
like
usually technology tries to innovate to
solve technologies problems that it sort
of created and you sort of have all
these knock-on second-order effects you
didn't expect like you built a
blockchain oh great oh and then someone
got docs on your blockchain okay well
let's build some way to do that do you
think that's that's viable or are you
like pessimistic about
our ability to do that i don't know
what i do know is it's way too early for
vulnerable people
to be
to be buying into
an ecosystem where
there is a billion dollars of venture
capital in there's
in social media influences creating hype
and getting paid for it and you've got
communities who are incentivized to hype
right and if someone isn't aware of
these three factors in the ecosystem
they could confuse that for an ability
to get rich now as a result of the nft
bay i've actually
had regulators from different
governments contact me because they
actually want to know about nfts they're
finding it very hard to actually find
someone who is not incentivized by nfts
because everyone they speak to has
either got a company or they've got
entities they're trying to sell
so they can't even get a straight answer
from a legislative point of view
meanwhile they're getting cut calls from
people in their country saying i
invested all this money and i'm left
holding the bag and i got scammed can
you please do something
well why are they going to you you have
all the nfts you're very heavily
incentivized to uh
you got all of them to talk well about
them um that's really interesting yeah i
imagine from a like a country standpoint
it's very hard to see it does feel like
people are divided either you have nfds
and you love nfts and you're bullish or
or you you think it's all a scam
you know it's going nowhere i mean for
me i think 99 of what's going on is a
scam this is try like a little bit it's
not really brave to say this is sort of
a common opinion i do think there will
be some future uses for nfts i think
that technology is pushing its way there
but i didn't know
the the data limitations just how steep
they were
on fees that really changes what i think
like maybe some of those innovations
could be because if it's going to be on
chain if it's going to get the benefits
of on on-chain the [ __ ] it just costs so
much money exactly
um that's actually the kind of the dirty
secret of the web 3 movement is how much
exists on standard internet
infrastructure like they claim
everything's on chain right but
the way to know if something's on chain
or not is really simple when you click a
button did you get charged for clicking
that button that it's it's that simple
data changes hands you had to pay for it
on websites exactly so that's how you
know
if if you're using a product say open c
and you click a link uh and you don't
get charged for it you're not that means
it's off chain
it's that simple so
and you'll know if you're paying because
i had to register an ens domain a couple
weeks so i'm bullish that something will
be found right but i think it's too
early for
the general
i think that's a good message pushed
into this right right where they don't
even know and and like you said even the
experts are struggling to know where
it's going why is the general population
having this like sort of shove down
their throats why has this been
mainlined into society when even the
people who build the technology don't
even know how
what we could do with the technology and
we're trying to still figure out the
technology and that's an underlying
message really to the nft community they
need to police their own community they
need to call out scammers in their
community and obvious pumps and dumps
and actually work to make sure the name
of nft is not tarnished because if they
don't regulators will step in and
regulate for them and that's going to be
a worse thing and they may never
actually find utility
yeah yeah i agree sometimes regulators
step in and they misunderstand the
technology and actually make the
situation worse yeah i i think i largely
agree with you here jeffrey and i think
your nft bay is a really interesting
project whether or not the pictures are
there or not
the nfts are there that's the crazy
thing is i'm really having a hard time
parsing from my brain that you own the
nfts but not the pictures i've just
thought that the nfts are the pictures
and vice versa and that's that's
one of the reasons that i've been
laughing for a little bit it was two
weeks ago since the launch
that one half is saying thank you for
backing up all the nfts we we fully
aware that the artwork
is not backed up on chain thank you for
backing it all up and at the same time
they're also saying that the artwork has
no value it's the contract the nft the
contract that has value meanwhile the
other side is the other side is saying
oh we're just going to right click save
the treasure the nft and they're saying
that
doesn't have value so essentially the
nft bay it's upside down
it contains the actual nfts not the
jpegs
it does it does make me wonder what
happens when all this web 2
infrastructure breaks down let's say you
have a google drive link that has your
image right and somebody forgets to keep
paying google for you know their extra
storage space or whatever your file gets
deleted now what is your nfd worth it's
happened it happens all the time people
have dropped millions on these contracts
that link to an image host and that
image host goes offline
like if it links to an internet domain
name and that domain name doesn't get
registered anymore that means anyone in
the world can go register that domain
name and they can put any image in that
person's art game oh boy
oh boy that's gonna go bad i know that's
gonna happen and when it yes it is that
is gonna be funny so is it true that
somebody screenshotted the nft bay
website and sold it
yeah it's true it's actually hilarious
uh vvd
uh vincent van doe
took a screenshot of the nft bay
and then
sold the hyperlink to the screenshot of
the nft bay
made eighteen thousand dollars for
selling the the treasure map to the
treasure with the image um and then i
took a screenshot
of his auction result and i turned that
into an entity and called it the
collector becomes the collected and that
is likely the only nft that i'll ever
create
in its current in collection and form
and well if you're going to be talking
about these things you you have to be
authentic you've got your actu how can
you talk about if you unless you have
done it so i created an nft of the nft
of the nft bay that can hold all the
nfts very interesting you're you're a
very interesting man jeffrey i will link
the website
um i hope you guys learned something
that was the whole intention when me and
jeffrey got together we said look we
want this to be educational i hope you
guys learned something thanks for
watching
and
yeah find out what you really own thanks
see ya